[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce numéro d'Yves avec
comme invité Bénédicte Marie bonjour
bonjour Patrice vous venez pour un livre
que vous venez de publier qui s'appelle
je suis né au sud du violon et c'est une
biographie de quelqu'un
je sais pas pourquoi on ne connaît pas
vraiment et c'est bien dommage qui
s'appelle Camille ursso oui c'est ça a
été tout mon tout mon questionnement en
fait quand j'ai écrit ce livre je me
suis dit pourquoi cette femme avec cette
destinée extraordinaire ce niveau de
notoriété française
voilà voilà non mais une française qui a
rayonné dans le monde entier pourquoi
cette femme est complètement effacée et
oublie aujourd'hui c'était le Apple
détonateur de l'écriture de de ce livre
alors on va situer les années à venir je
prends en 1840 et elle est morte en 1902
c'est ça
pour situer l'époque et c'est une
violoniste
formidable violoniste seulement voilà à
l'époque
c'était pas bien vu pour les femmes de
jouer d'un instrument autre golf piano
alors le piano ça allait piano d'une
bonne jeune fille dans les bonnes
familles jouer du piano le dimanche
après-midi après le thé on les écoutait
tout allait bien c'était pas c'était pas
risqué mais alors les autres instruments
pas question oui le piano on considérait
que que c'était un instrument d'agrément
qui voilà la mère de famille ou l'épouse
agrémenté son foyer aujourd'hui du piano
la jeune fille attire les prétendants
par ce biais là mais le violon c'était
absolument il n'avait pas d'interdiction
mais c'était une interdiction tacite en
fait parce que on est quand même on faut
resituer le contexte on est dans la
France poste napoléonienne et le violon
avait des actions très martiaux très
belliqueux et voilà et et donc c'était
absolument indécent que surtout parce
que la femme au 19e siècle elle devait
être discrète elle devait rester dans
son intérieur elle devait pas faire de
vagues et voilà la fougue qu'exigeait la
pratique du violon voilà ça ne
correspondez pas
et pourtant alors cette amélioration qui
n'est à Nantes c'est ça de avec la paire
musicien enfin des parents qui sont dans
la musique comment elle découvre le
violon alors c'est une sorte une
révélation c'est presque une
transcendance parce qu'elle est elle a 7
ans elle est dans une église dans les
glissante croix à Nantes et elle entend
la Messe en si mineur de bac et à partir
de ce moment là elle se dit il se dit
ben ce sera ma vie quoi c'est ce que je
dis dans le livre et ce sera mon
instrument et je serai je serai les
siens voilà alors elle commence à jouer
de violon elle est extrêmement douée
pour les cours avec un professeur je
crois de l'orchestre de Nantes c'est ça
au départ c'est ça oui les amis de son
père qui s'appelle Félix Simon et qui
est premier violon à l'Opéra Théâtre
câlin et voilà qui va être le premier
initiateur il faut pas qu'elle reste là
il faut qu'elle aille faire le
Conservatoire de Paris c'est ça oui
je pense que au début il accepte un peu
en freinant des quatre fermes parce que
c'est une fille et ensuite
il est presque dépassé parce qu'il
découvre et par le
maestria de cet enfant qui en plus qui
est minuscule qui est très petite de
taille et voilà il se dit je pense que
inconsciemment il se dit bientôt je ne
vais plus suffire à cet enfant pour la
faire progresser donc il faut l'envoyer
au Conservatoire de Paris seulement là
il y a jusqu'à elle très très peu de
femmes on dit souvent qu'il y a c'est la
première c'est pas tout à fait la
première c'est pas vrai non non c'est la
troisième mais bon en 60 ans parce que
le le
conservatoire
a été ouvert après la Révolution
1795 si je ne dis pas de bêtises et elle
elle toque à sa porte en
1849 donc il y a eu deux femmes dans les
classes de corde pas de violon c'est de
cordes dans l'eau c'est la première et
voilà
Aubert qui est le le directeur de
conservatoire de l'époque Aubert alors
on connaît plus maintenant la rue ou de
la station
ils étaient directement
douée voilà elle a elle finit le
Conservatoire elle a quel âge 12 ans
enfin 12 ans oui oui en fait quand
Camille entre conservatoire elle a à
peine 9 ans depuis quelques jours ce qui
est là je minimum dans le les règlements
de l'école et elle elle la quitte après
trois ans de d'études à 12 ans seulement
voilà et elle part assez vite faire une
tournée aux États-Unis hein on va voir
que les études ont une grande importance
dans sa vie
est-ce que c'était plus facile
des questions se pose aux États-Unis
qu'en Europe le voir une femme
violéeiste par exemple
je ne sais pas si c'était plus c'était
plus facile mais il y avait quand même
un appétit de culture parce que c'était
le nouveau monde et on était très
friands de ce qui venait d'Europe et
parce que c'est quand même c'est quand
même l'époque où beaucoup de colons
aussi installés ou si c'était installé
dans les décennies précédentes donc non
je pense pas que c'était nécessairement
plus plus facile mais et il y avait
peut-être plus de curiosité envers les
envers les artistes la nouveauté aussi
et alors c'est vrai qu'elle se pose des
questions elle se dit au fou parce que
il y a un vrai problème bon finalement à
force de volonté et puis de talent et de
génie même elle elle a un parcours
d'études classiques tout à fait
[Musique]
normal enfin si je peux dire le problème
c'est qu'à l'époque même si vous êtes
comme Camille yourso une biologie sortie
du conservatoire des orchestres ne
veulent pas c'est ça oui mais ça c'est
quelque chose qui
auquel elle s'est attaquée plus tard
dans sa carrière parce que c'est vrai
que que tout le début de sa trajectoire
ça a été de de
s'imposer dans son dans son milieu dans
son métier parce qu'elle était femme
presque on peut dire en dépit son état
de femme et je pense que ça a été que
dans un son second temps ou ou elle
s'est dit là il y a un problème parce
que
moi Camille et d'autres
d'autres
violonistes de prodiges de l'époque nous
avons ouvert les portes mais
si les les portes des des écoles des
académies des conservateurs sont
ouvertes sous l'ordre leur impulsion à
ces femmes prodiges mais une fois
qu'elles étaient formées parce que après
il y en a eu beaucoup beaucoup
1870 1880 on a eu beaucoup mais personne
n'est embaucher donc c'est un
et ça a été il y avait cette ce
sentiment quand même et c'est on
retrouve d'ailleurs la même chose en
politique quand il s'agit de savoir si
si on pouvait dire des femmes par
exemple
j'ai vu des débats au Sénat qui était
formidable qui disait attendez mais si
il y a des femmes qui siègent parmi nous
ça va tourner la tête des hommes ils
vont plus savoir et un peu c'est un peu
ça dans les ordres
elles vont elles vont semer la zizanie
quoi ça ça va être impossible de garder
de l'ordre avec des femmes c'est ça
c'est c'est à la en fait c'est à la fin
de la vie de Camille et que enfin au
moment où elle est elle est morte en
1902 en fait enfin je j'en ris mais
c'est
elle va s'installer aux États-Unis elle
va finir sa vie aux États-Unis mais
c'est une carrière internationale c'est
une star internationale et
dit c'est incroyable qu'on la
connaissent pas vous citer un article
d'un journal français qui parle de sa
mort qui dit Camille sous l'artiste
italiennes même en France on sait même
pas c'est ça
incroyable mais alors en France on a su
qu'il y avait on a su qui elle était
parce qu'elle est quand même elle est
revenue beaucoup pendant sa carrière
notamment jouer auprès des proches de de
Napoléon III elle est revenue jouer avec
leur caisse du Conservatoire donc elle
est venue elle est elle était célèbre en
France mais elle a pas eu la notoriété
aux États-Unis et ailleurs parce qu'on
en a pas encore parlé mais elle a été
Afrique du Sud elle a rempli des salles
vous avez vu le jubilé qu'elle a fait en
1869 à San Francisco où il y avait
jusqu'à 18000 personnes par jour mais
c'était c'est Lady Gaga de
19e sur le plan privé elle a eu de Marie
c'est ça
qui est mort
prématuré
qui était c'était un homme moderne parce
que il a il a accepté il a accepté des
voilà il a été son impréario
toutes les années une saison passée
ensemble elle a été son après-sario et
vous avez dû voir dans le livre je cite
un article où il dit bien conscient qui
ne peut y avoir que qu'un seul génie
dans la famille voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà et elle l'a fait il y a eu ce
point d'orgue de de son discours voilà
alors c'est en fait c'est dans le cadre
de l'Exposition Universelle
colombienne de
1893 en fait il y avait un bâtiment qui
s'appelait le woman Building et en fait
il y a eu les oratrices éminent de se
succéder à la tribune et Camille a été
l'une d'entre elles et elle a elle a eu
un discours
incroyablement là aussi
avant-gardiste parce qu'elle on est
quand même en 1893 elle elle a plaidé
l'embauche des femmes l'égalité
salariale enfin des choses c'est là
qu'elle commence à me dépasser jusque là
elle se disait au fond c'est mon art qui
me définit et là elle sent qu'elle a
aussi une cause à défendre qui est la
cause des femmes c'est ça
elle m'a emporté Camille maroté parce
que je soupçonnais pas tout ce que tout
ce que j'allais découvrir à son à son
propos parce que quand on sonde la
presse américaine en ligne mais c'est
incroyable j'ai même pas pu tout inclure
tellement c'est riche
on oublie de l'histoire c'est absolument
incroyable alors je vous presse un petit
peu malheureusement et vous lit parlez
d'un livre de d'Odile Lefranc qui
s'appelle le lac au miroir
parce que vous allez être je dis ça tout
de suite vous allez être cultura vilaine
Orgeval le 27 mai pour une dédicace de
10h20 salon de 10h à 18h c'est ça une
dédicace marathon on va dire et Odile le
France sera avec vous c'est ça c'est ça
et
on a comme point commun qui sont son
livre parle d'art aussi et que c'est
la quête initiatique d'une héroïne qui
qui tente de de fuir sa famille sa
relation douloureuse avec sa mère et en
partant à Bali ben elle va elle va
renouer que ses racines et par
l'entremise d'un peintre qui s'appelle
Walter je pisse voilà
excellente éditrice alors je vous disais
vous serez au salon culture
cheval pardon le 27 mai de 10h à 18h
vous dites c'est un marathon et puis
deux jours avant
vous êtes au Cercle National de l'armée
à Paris pour un salon des femmes de
lettres
ou il y aura
notamment
[Musique]
Dominique Bona violette durceau oui je
suis en très bonne compagnie
voilà voilà je rappelle le titre de
votre livre je suis né au son du violon
la vie de Camille yourso première
musicienne féministe
c'est donc Bénédicte Marie merci
infiniment
[Musique]